Narrator: INTRODUCING
THE UNDERWATER JET PACK.
WEAR IT AND FREESTYLE FASTER
THAN MICHAEL PHELPS.
EAT YOUR HEART OUT, AQUAMAN.
Gradman:
ANYTIME YOU CAN USE TECHNOLOGY
TO GIVE HUMAN BEINGS
SUPERPOWERS, I'M ALL-IN.
Narrator: WE'VE PADDLED
TO PORTSMOUTH, ENGLAND,
TO ASK INVENTOR SIMON PARK
WHAT PROMPTED
THIS AQUATIC AWESOMENESS.
Park: I CREATED
THE UNDERWATER JET PACK
TO ENABLE PEOPLE
TO FLY UNDERWATER.
REALLY, IT'S AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
I'VE ALWAYS HAD
THIS KIND OF PASSION
FOR TRYING TO DEVELOP
THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT WE WERE PROMISED AS KIDS
BUT WERE NEVER DELIVERED.
YOU KNOW, YOU WATCH
THE JAMES BOND MOVIES,
AND, REALLY,
THOSE KIND OF THINGS
CAPTURED MY IMAGINATION
AS A CHILD.
AND I WAS LEFT
AS AN ADULT SAYING,
"WHERE'S MY JET PACK?
WHERE'S MY JET PACK?"
Narrator:
THERE'S YOUR JET PACK.
BUT HOW DOES IT WORK?
THIS UNDERWATER JET PACK
IS COMPOSED
OF TWO THRUSTERS,
ONE ON EACH ARM,
WHICH ARE POWERED
BY TWO LITHIUM POLYMER BATTERIES
IN A BACKPACK
THAT THE SWIMMER WEARS.
AND YOU CONTROL IT
WITH A HANDHELD THROTTLE.
Gradman:
PRESS THE THROTTLE BUTTON,
AND THE THRUSTERS POWER UP,
DRIVING YOU THROUGH THE WATER.
THESE THRUSTERS WORK
BY MEANS OF PROPELLERS.
Wrigglesworth:
WHAT SIMON HAS DONE
IS ENCASE EACH PROPELLER
INTO A SPECIAL DUCTING
CALLED A KORT NOZZLE.
Gradman:
KORT NOZZLE HAS A CROSS SECTION
MUCH LIKE
THE WING OF AN AIRPLANE.
IT'S SHAPED SO THAT
AS WATER MOVES BACKWARDS
ALONG ITS LENGTH,
IT GETS THROUGH
A SMALLER AND SMALLER APERTURE.
WHAT THAT MEANS
IS THAT THE WATER
IS FORCED TO ACCELERATE
BECAUSE WATER CAN'T COMPRESS.
THAT WATER JETS OUT
THE BACK OF THE THRUSTER,
AND THE USER GOES SCREAMING
THROUGH THE WATER.
Park:
IF YOU SKYDIVE, YOU'LL KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT IT FEELS LIKE.
IT'S ACTUALLY EVEN MORE INTENSE.
YOU KNOW, WATER'S
1,000 TIMES DENSER THAN AIR.
SO, YOU KNOW, WE MIGHT ONLY BE
DOING 6 OR 7 MILES AN HOUR,
BUT WHEN YOU SCALE THAT SPEED
AGAINST AIRSPEED,
IT'S FEROCIOUS.
I CALL IT UNDERWATER HYPERDRAFT.
Narrator:
AND WE CALL IT AWESOME.